I'm supposed to be meeting my friend downtown and my phone is dead
And I'm just afraid that she won't be able to get to me. Um, would it be possible? I know it's a lot to ask...
You wouldn't happen o have a phone I could borrow would you?
*Ambient paced music*
Excuse me, excuse me sir.
could I ask you a question really quickly?
No, Sorry.
Aw, thanks...
Uh, not really. No.
You wouldn't happen to have a phone I could borrow, would you?
Yea, man.
Yea, thanks a lot. I just from out of town and I got off on the wrong bus stop.
It's all good, no worries.
I will just stand right here, ok?
OK, uh, uh, uh, Sure.
Do you want to use mine?
Could I please? Thank you so much.
Sure, you want to use my phone?
Yea.
Thank you so much.
That happened to me last night.
you don't get that request a lot, so...
It's in the United states, yea?
Yes! Definitely, definitely.
He's not answering... Um, this is...
I'm about to order a drink, you want to use it on the way out?
Are you ok?
Yea, I'm fine. I just need, need them to come pick me up and everything is good.
Use it again, dude.
Yea, I could try one more time, but...
You can also send them a text message, if you like.
No sexting...
I won't sext on your phone.
Give them a call if you want to
I'll try it.
we could try again
I'd freak the F%#$ out. wait, do you need like a cell phone charger or what?
you can use the charger in my car really quick.
do you want to charge it while we go get coffee?
do you want to charge it in our car?
There's a hat store right across the street and there's AC in there. Go in there and like hang out.
*Upbeat acoustic instrumental*
This is crazy but would you happen to have a dollar I could borrow to get back on the bus to get back to downtown?
Yea...
Ah, you're amazing!
thank you so much
thank you
thanks a lot
no problem
Bam!
Take that just in case
Oh, that you that is so... you did not... five dollars!
Well, we work at a ******* so, if you like need a place, a cool place to wait.
We have a VICE magazines while you wait.
We're like chilling in the back so you can just come to the fitting rooms.
you guys are so nice.
You know what, you ladies are the nicest people in the world. have you ever seen the website BuzzFeed?
Yes
Yes, this is for BuzzFeed we're just seeing how nice people are.
You're very wonderful!
We won!
Yea, that's what we're doing. There's a camera right there
Camera's right there. Thanks a lot for being kind and here's your two dollars back.
Right on, man
Thanks a lot man
Thank you, very nice. Thank you so much
Thank you, guys. That was so nice of you. Thank you
Just come in and um, go to the fitting room.
Well I have a car *Laughing*
It's right there
Ok!